people i believe are good people are
good per se
they want to do good things however
sometimes it's not easy
to do good things sometimes you want to
i don't know you want to
plan a tree but where how with who how
you're going to do it
and like this like so many other
initiatives so many other things that
you might want to do
and it's difficult so what we want to do
is to make it
super easy we don't want any excuses
from businesses
you know if you want to do good tell us
how and we will help you
[Music]
mark sirera thank you so much for
joining me in 20 minute leaders how are
you
i'm very good thank you it's still
covered 19.
we have the distance we're here in a
beautiful paramount hotel in dubai
and mark you're an entrepreneur you're
but you're originally from barcelona but
here you are
in dubai and and i can't wait to talk to
you a little bit about doing good for
the world and helping companies do good
so tell me a little bit about yourself
and what are you doing here in dubai
sure so
well i started uh doing business and
then at some point i realized that
i needed something a bit more meaningful
in my life i wanted to make a larger
impact than just
making money for the sake of it and so
at that point i went to australia to do
a master's in business ethics
and that really kind of motivated me to
to get into this sector of
sustainability
csr business ethics to help businesses
make money uh while doing good
right so but you're originally not from
dubai is he still from barcelona you
spent some time in australia
what brought you to dubai correct love
brought me here
so before coming here i was in london i
was working there
as a csr consultant then i quit my job i
left the city i just was looking for new
experiences and i went to south america
to travel
and while there i met the love of my
life
who she was working here at the time and
and i just followed her here and here i
am now
beautiful and you're raising a family
here and mark you're you're an
entrepreneur you're a different kind of
entrepreneur because
your focus is not just on taking a
business and growing it exponentially
you know the regular hockey stick but
your focus is on on doing things that do
good for the environment and do good for
the world
while helping other companies do that
tell me a little bit about why you
why you're even in this doing good space
yes so normally i don't call myself an
entrepreneur i call myself a social
entrepreneur
right because for me just starting a
business without having this element
of giving back to society it's it was
not really like meaningful
so whenever i thought about creating
something it was always
uh with this purpose-driven kind of
goal and and so i created companies for
goods
which is a social enterprise and we help
businesses
do good and as you were saying it's not
the typical
i would say startup in the sense that
we're not really looking at growing fast
and raising funds and
and making it huge we're just looking at
doing things well
and enjoying the journey as well which i
think is super important uh
i've seen lots of entrepreneurs suffer a
lot while creating their
startups and i'm sure you are a witness
of
or having talked with so many people of
how
tough the journey can be right and how
people sometimes are always looking for
for funds or they are like struggling to
to to make things happen and so for me
that was that was
something very important i set three
big objectives when setting up companies
for good
one was to make it profitable to make
money
one was to make a positive impact
on society and the planet and the third
one was to have a
good life while doing it good work life
balance
so these were the three kind of elements
of of the
startup right i think that's a very
interesting trend that we see today
unlike a lot of different timelines in
the world that now we have social
entrepreneurs that are realizing that
it's not just about you know doing
non-profit work and just
volunteering their time but you have to
make it also profitable business you
have to make
a positive social contribution to the
world while also
having a profitable startup that can
actually you know
generate revenue and keep sustaining
because if you want to make an impact
and i remember i i read a quote on the
one day that really transformed me
you know if you if you make an impact on
a billion people you'll also make a
billion dollars they go hand in hand
it's not just about doing good but it
has to be a two-way street
because it also you have to have a good
team that is working on it you have to
attract the best talent to work for this
and i think so i think that's very
inspiring mark before we go into
companies for a good more i'd love to
for you to tell me a little bit about
your experience here in dubai what have
you observed in the ecosystem you've
worked with different companies you've
seen different vcs and incubators what
what is happening here in dubai
there are lots of things happening i've
seen the
startup seen change a lot in the past
five years
there are so many accelerator programs
incubators
and and generally like the ecosystem is
is growing a lot
i think it's an amazing place to start
up
anything any project any business it's a
it's a place full of opportunities here
and so
and it's fairly easy as well in terms of
bureaucracy i mean it's fairly easy to
set up
your business and start operating and
start invoicing and start
working within almost hours sometimes
that's pretty crazy because because
you've had also different experiences
with bureaucracy and you've observed
different countries and how they operate
so how is that different
yes it's absolutely different so before
having uh
companies for good here i had the
business back home which is
uh barcelona and over there the
bureaucracy
is a nightmare it's like it's uh
it's so complicated to set up a business
it's so costly even before you start
operating
you really need to pay lots of taxes and
you need to pay fees and
it takes days if not months to to be
able to
to start working and start doing
something and that's
really not good for the entrepreneurs
kind of ecosystem right we what we need
we
we are young people are not so young but
with lots of ideas we want to make
things happen
and if the institutions keep putting all
these barriers then
they're just making things way more
difficult right so tell a little bit
about about what's happening with the
world and
you know you're coming in and saying you
know we have all these great
organizations that are looking to
have you know these bonding group
experiences but while also making a
positive impact on the world
what is happening to the world where
companies are having this shift where
they're looking to have these
impactful projects that you've observed
which triggered you're doing companies
for good
yeah i think two things are happening
one is that
people are more aware nowadays about
things that are not really going as we
would like to in the world
in terms of like climate change right
like it's on the agenda of all
governments everybody's talking about it
in terms of social inequalities
diversity and inclusion there are so
many things that perhaps
in the 70s 80s businesses could just
carry on
and people were looking the other way
but now it's not happening anymore
everybody's way more accountable
and businesses also are more like
aware and they need to do more things
the other one is that
people i believe are good people are
good per se
they want to do good things however
sometimes it's not easy
to do good things sometimes you want to
i don't know you want to
plan a tree but where how um with who
how are you going to do it
and like this like so many other
initiatives so many other things that
you might want to do
and it's difficult so what we want to do
is to make it
super easy we don't want any excuses
from businesses
you know if you want to do good tell us
how and we will help you
so that's why we're seeing that people
really and people and when i mean people
i mean companies are made by people
so when i talk about companies i always
think about the people making up
those companies right because
i think it happens a lot that people
talk about oh microsoft is this and that
or i don't know that other company or
coca-cola these sorry i'm dropping names
here but
these are worldwide and and who who are
these brands like i mean they're they're
just legal names and behind those uh
names
there are loads of people and lots of
different people who care about
different things who have families who
live
within the planet and so it's those
people that we're talking to
when we are offering our support to them
in the sense of how do you want to make
a positive contribution
with your colleagues in this case do you
guys want to do something for
the refugee community you want to do
something for those who are suffering
cancer
do you want to support children do you
want to protect the environment so
we know that people care about those
things and we just
give them the opportunity to do
something about it so what it also means
that you've identified a gap
between a desire that people want so
like in economics you have like the
supply and demand there's a lot of
demand there's not really supply because
people might know that they want to do
certain things but they have no idea as
to how they're going to go do it how do
i plan a tree
how do i help families that are that are
in need right
and and so you're creating this platform
where you're helping bridge that gap and
saying
you want to do good i know how to do the
good and i can just
help you leverage your human capital and
financial capital to go and do that
give me a little a broad spectrum of
what types of activities do you actually
do
and how do you go about taking companies
and make them happen so in terms of
activities
we have many different ones we
categorize them between doing good for
the environment
or doing good for the communities for
the environment we do
beach cleanups we do tree plantings we
do
forest reforestations we do underwater
cleanup
with divers on the ocean we do cleanups
on the desert
so we do many different actions that are
about
keeping our planet clean and trying to
keep the air as as
healthy and possible in terms of like
offsetting co2 emissions
then for the communities we have
activities to support children
to support people of determination which
are like people with
special needs here we call them people
of determination
and we take groups of employees to go to
a center where there are like
children with special needs and they
teach them they play with them they read
books to them etc
we have activities to support refugees
um
people that are suffering from cancer so
many different like initiatives that
you can do something with your
colleagues and that has a positive
impact on that certain community than
mine did
right so what's been what's been the
most both easiest and hardest part of
this journey
because i imagine that it you know every
every company that you work with it's a
different challenge it's a different
it's a different flow but over you know
you mentioned you're doing hundreds of
projects
what what's bit what's the pattern of
the easiest and the hardest things that
you've had to overcome
the easiest is to make people happy
people love doing these things
and and i i cannot repeat it enough
times
when we start one of our activities
everybody arrives there a bit like not
grumpy but the level of energy is
not that high so for instance let's
imagine a beach cleanup right yeah
we say to to a company there that group
of employees that are coming like
we meet at 9 00 a.m and we will start
they were having an am a little sleepy
like
often they don't know their colleagues
or they don't know that much because in
the office the kind of relationships
established with people might be
different from outside the office right
over the office there are lots of
hierarchies or
your day-to-day work wherever that is
so people don't talk much among
themselves they're not really like
laughing
not really engaged time keeps passing
they keep doing
things together and then by 11 12 when
they finish the activity
there's such a hype there the level of
energy is huge people are laughing
they're talking about each other much
more and we asked them afterwards you
know like
have you met anyone uh neo yeah we met
lots of colleagues i didn't know and
uh they love doing a cleanup for some
people
only the idea of picking up trash might
be a bit like i don't know where are
people who
work on that why do i need to go and
clean up but once you're there
and you see the real impact you're
making on nature it
it something happens something quiet
magic that it
lifts you up they call it the givers
glow as well
so it's a bit like i don't know you feel
fulfilled you feel happy you feel you've
done
something good and we see that all the
time with the with the groups that we're
taking
to do this kind of activities that they
end up super excited they end up
obviously much more aware of the
situation whether it's the environment
of the community but
it's that feeling that people have that
wow we we've done something good we've
done it together
and and that's exciting that's really
good now
moving a little bit more to the you know
to the business side of things because
that's always something that i'm very
curious about how do you get companies
to
know who you are and to understand the
value of companies for good because it's
not every day
that a company wakes up and says huh
maybe i should take my team to do a
beach cleanup today
oh and by the way there's this mark from
companies for good so how does this
whole cycle work
you know you would be surprised that
there are many people that wake up one
day and say oh i want to do something
with my team
there are loads of them and and we're
not talking about like
the ceo or the the vice president
of a company we're talking about a team
leader you could be the head of hr and
you have a team of seven people under
you or the head of finance or
and these people it's not their area of
expertise right to organize activities
they have other other kind of day-to-day
jobs to do
and normally they want to do something a
bit original something a bit meaningful
and perhaps they heard about the escape
rooms uh go-karting or
some similar activities they want to do
something like a bit more
impactful and they don't know what they
don't know
what to do or what they could do and so
when they found that when they find us
they're really excited
we had i think a very rare position in
the market since the beginning which
i think we're very blessed about which
is the clients are happy when they found
us
we we haven't done any like outreach any
sales
we've been of course we've done like
some marketing and we tried you know to
position our ourselves in google
in the rankings it's not that we've been
just sitting and people like came
we worked one of actually things are for
that aggregate yeah it's a really
interesting thing that you mentioned was
that
you know this is a pretty niche market
people don't often search for beach
cleanup
or planting trees on google and that's
that's one of the ways you've reached
your client base
that yes that's that's helped us a lot
that it we're in a niche market
and so we've done a little bit of search
engine optimization
um on our website and and a little bit
of link building and and
writing blogs etc so when people wanted
to find us
it would be easier and and so in google
we ran quite well because of that
because it's
fairly niche and we've done an effort
but also like
we we're working with lots of businesses
that come to us because of word of mouth
so they they ask around like oh what can
we do to
to do an activity that gives back to
society or that helps the environment
and then
after having a couple of conversations
they're like oh you know you should
contact companies for good they organize
these kind of things
but but as i was saying like since the
beginning i was
shocked when the phone would ring and it
would be
i don't know i work for dhl i work for
caleb's i work for hsbc i work for
amazon i'm like okay and so how can i
help you oh
we heard you do i don't know tree
planting this kind of tv like yeah we
can help
oh yeah please that would be amazing
because i've been looking for it i was
like okay sure
how you know can we do it next week yeah
sure this is the price okay fine
so it's been surprisingly
i wouldn't say easy because this is uh
undermining what because we worked hard
for it but it's been
a pleasant journey let's put this way
that's incredible
what's next what's the vision for
companies for good well that's a very
good a
very good question what we have done a
lot this year
is go digital yeah like
everyone else right it's it's no no news
but all our activities were physical
team activities with with teams
corona came and we had to cancel every
single activity
in feb we did i don't know about 20
activities
we had more than 20 booked for march it
was our best
month ever we were like growing uh a lot
it was amazing everything was like
fantastic
and then boom so from one week to
another everything got cancelled
everything got canceled and we were like
okay this is gonna last like one month
or like one year or ten years who knows
but we quickly like reinvented ourselves
and we
while the situation was you know tough
in terms of uh
physical team activities we started to
create online things
and so now we have a very cool uh team
building activity called the climate
change challenge
and this is like hundreds of people can
play online
normally they do it like in teams of a
company and they
it's a group of echo heroes they travel
around the world and
they go to different continents
discovering what is the climate change
issue that is affecting the most in that
area they need to overcome different
challenges and games
and they keep moving on like some kind
of competing among teams but learning at
the same time and having
having some fun and and that's that's
been
[Music]
kind of a a positive thing from this uh
challenging year and i think in terms of
the vision that that's where we want to
go
more because physical team activities
are fantastic and it creates this kind
of hype
but you're it's a bit more limited in
terms of where you can do it
and we also have many businesses that
are international right and so they have
an office here but they also have an
office in oman another one in saudi
another one in qatar or elsewhere
and often they want to do activities
among their teams to bring them together
but cross-border and how can you do that
online right
right so what are some nuggets of advice
you you can provide for some
young social entrepreneurs that are on
their journey obviously it's a very
different type of journey than
you know the average entrepreneur that
is just trying to raise money for a
first startup that is on the hockey
stick
trajectory what what what what should
young entrepreneurs need to know
as they're embarking on this social
adventure
i think two things are very very
important and
one is give
offer to your customers what they might
want or need
not what you like or what you think
they might need like i've seen so many
both normal entrepreneurs are social
entrepreneurs i don't know why i'm
calling them normal but
whatever like non-social entrepreneurs
and social entrepreneurs
that they're so passionate about their
idea
and what what they want to do that they
have
missed on checking with
their customers their clients if that's
what they want or how they want it
and they spend a year working on that
product or service
hidden you know in a room or something
investing a lot of money
even like spending a lot of time
thinking about the name or the logo
and then once they go out there after
year obviously they have
no money and almost no energy because
they're working so hard
and then often they find that the
customers want something else or that
uh they want it differently and and so
it's it's a very very
kind of clashing situation whereas i
always tell people you know whenever you
have
a little tiny thing go out there go out
there start operating start learning
and and that worked for me very well
because
when i started companies for good i went
out there without having a business
license
without like the website it was made by
me and i
have no idea how to make websites one of
these like pre-made things
the logo was made by a friend and it was
a disaster logo so
i mean and but so what and and we
started learning
and we started already engaging with
customers some customers liked some of
the ideas and they already like started
doing activities which helped us
finance our our next steps and so on so
it's
it's been um i think a growth
journey and a smooth journey because of
this
kind of action-driven uh attitude of
let's get out there and let's start
working and then we will be polishing
and improving things as we go
wow so that that's definitely one piece
of advice and the other one is obviously
like believe in what you do be
passionate about it because
there's so many bumps on the journey so
many difficulties that unless
unless you you like what you're doing
and you believe in it it's
it's uh you're not gonna enjoy it and
that what's the point of setting up a
business if you don't enjoy it
right 100 mark i want to thank you for
being so gracious with your time
and you know this is one of the few that
we managed to do in person and i'm happy
that we're able to do this in a
social distancing context and here in
dubai but before we leave i have to put
you on the spot for one last question
okay which is three words that you would
use to describe yourself
or your wife would use to describe you
or any of the companies that you got to
work with
wow three words um maybe i would say
action-driven person action-driven
person
yeah i make things happen i love that
mark
thank you very very much stay safe stay
healthy and continue doing good for the
world literally
and helping a lot of other companies do
it and i'm sure by the way that that
it's not just limited to that event when
they come and work with you but but it's
it's a ripple effect right and they take
it then to their home
to their colleagues they tell their
families and it's creating you know a
butterfly effect where you know
it's a net the network effects is
exponential and
you work it just ricochets so thank you
very very much thank you so much